j'ai besoin de vous d'ailleurs je gomme
qui n'appuie pardon il faut que j'aie
chappe à mon mari
vous devriez me frapper tanks et des
marques
si j'avais un truc est fort c'est
impossible aux pièces bouquet arabe
de l'argent somme de la brigade
criminelle scénique ça me charger de
l'enquète vous pouvez nous dire quel
genre de femme c'était je pense que ma
femme est terrifiée je crois que chaque
seconde qu'elle passe avec celui qui a
fait ça est un enfer mairie c'est
quelqu'un de fragile
il faut savoir qu'avec des obsessions
qui suit en temps ce qui nous prend pour
des cons
à
cependant m
je te tueras pas comme ça j'ai plus rien
à perdre
vous aviez votre femme se sentit suivi
pour que moi j'attends
simon pegg d'aller voir les flics et de
leur dire la vérité quelle vérité